that is a gorgeous 16 in the morning Oh
scary regard is me today good morning
good morning good morning good morning
it's day 3 that means today is Saturday
assistant it's lots of kids days we got
kids everywhere we are leading off with
some fragments smoothie me if I Nina
look at that not looks like Yemeni it is
seven thirty in the morning and we are a
wink and ready to go because we're
excited that is Disney day we got we got
25 minutes to eat and leave and crush
them Disney we're going to disney today
we're excited to go we're going to hit
off the epcot have a great day how did
you sleep Nina I'm not that well not
that well well you know what solves a
bad night's sleep Coffee a very busy day
that's that's the solution just work a
lot the next day that's a really good at
life
this is it we're here Jeffrey's excited
to date in the ground Nina Stephanie our
backyard also excited I like him son lux
on my face right now coming in nicely
that's where we're going siemens very
excited why oh well that's a hike
excited I just excited by all the zoo
we basically came to business about the
kids Nina can catch up everyone let's
not mean it really cares occur right
[Music]
it's team evidence Stephanie can't leave
me that it's Jeffrey
he's gonna weigh nothing's going to take
a fast one look at that shine finish
number two that is a crazy car Jeffrey
this is Stephanie in my car boom boom
this is hayden Jeffrey and Nina's car
boomba let's see who wins rocketship car
[Music]
[Music]
my hair was all over the place okay guys
how was that oh look at Nina's hair look
his name is fair all right next up we're
going to go on the brand new frozen ride
ride a boat through the land of frozen
let's see here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
we had a great time on my knee mega job
ok so this lineup is crazy and nina
hasn't had her top it yet so let me kill
two birds with one stone well Nina waits
in line i'm going to run back the
entrance give you some coffee here we go
alright i made it was just a line up out
the door here to say a lineup today all
right it'll starbucks is a 40-minute
wait which means a Victor Baxter we want
to get the crowd I was
hey you want the company if the share
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
how was it you like to miss there for
the first I mean all right time to go
get some lunch I'm going to run ahead
and order Mina in this life 16 in the
morning Oh scary scene in the morning is
pretty scary
[Music]
there's our lunch efficient ship how is
it good ticket bite Hopstop walk how was
it mr. wow good he didn't try something
that was it yummy Stephanie good Nina
Jimmy all right time to eat well you're
gonna check you up there we got a billy
full of food okay we're gonna go do some
story and toy you know the fun ride it
was closed last year we couldn't go on
it so I think if we have never been on
and he didn't think was too small the
first time I don't think until nobody's
been on like steffanina and I so it'll
be fun we're here inside sorry we're
going to get a tour what we're supposed
to do in phila to the screen Jeffrey's
excited mean is excited I'm going to
sample
Seph is excited I'm not your uncle by
the way and hayden is excited so excited
look at that excited face lean is
excited to film inside party on the
other side what magic how was it going
next year it's all good you can smell
things the picture on your desk and I
sent to your face we didn't have the
orange see this you know sorry but we
got to smell a bunch of jumbles up the
standby time is 100 minutes that's why
you book fast passes and plan ahead you
don't wait in that line
[Music]
this is Nina she's been a very patient
and happy today and I think she deserves
a starbucks coffee on me ya see that
excitement that's more excited than a
ride for Nina so I brought it to
starbucks look at that look at that
timing Nina got his drink
oh yeah the green tea green tea is good
for you this is one hundred percent good
for you because it's green tea guys and
I learned
alright next ride
text up no we're going into the future
got to finish our things so we go in
have a brief free to bring a drink the
Tongass frozen peas that it was getting
good all right here we go
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what am I most interested in eating or
where would you like to work in the
future the city what's your ideal work
environment energy of an office where do
you get your best ideas everywhere thank
you very much too so
what's in your bag only what I need guys
implicitly put the statue back I live
the work I work to live I love to work
how do you want to chop on the teacher
the car that drives itself or Hubbert
rate let's go kart a time so hey what
can you tell you that guy look at that
sexy guy in the future he will be a
great place to work nice wow look at my
eyes the innovation park with global
networking and the latest digital cool
to turn your dreams into reality
that board meeting at the beach Wow no
problem all right I'm a surfer you'll be
able to look at that car car by myself I
happy guy I was it a little slow funny
i'm liking and the closet it's help you
want to wear every day okay are you
going to do so in the future i think
could we i'm usually with somebody so
you take you should pick life right so i
was on myself to pick work and I said
I'd like the energy of an office and
then it has been working from the beach
I don't work on the beat I want to work
on the beach guys I don't want to work I
want to work in an office to get stuff
done I don't want to walk on the beach
Whistler from the beach want to work
with offering get stuff done and upset
about my future you know what I'm not
going to accept that future the solution
I'm going to make my own future take
that left our future to make my own
forget to work from an office and get
lots of stuff done and I'm not making
surfboards either making something more
valuable impactful changing
entrepreneurs
Oh Nina hello Oh was it I feel like
these steps of Mexico are a lot shorter
than last time fancy meeting you here
imagine meeting you business where we
haven't I seen you here before feel like
I've seen you here before it's a very
special place for us oh we met you we
met here in Mexico last year we were
here Oh who's this hello what's your
name huh imagine meeting you in a place
like this I get the same with me now
from run and just behind us behind us
[Music]
what do you think of the right Haven
awesome we're going to run the ice cream
we're going to run the ice cream I told
the kids would either go slowly and just
go to the figment ride or we can rush
and do ice cream and big prizes it's
what they want to do
[Music]
he's having some rum in her coffee in
her ice cream
hey don't get drunk he never there she
goes you know it's not on the menu off
the menu what do you think strong how's
the ice cream double P
really yeah go go Nina's having a hard
time with the ice cream okay you like
your um your aroma holic yeah finish
that up drinking down I can take it down
stay down it gets lonely chug chug chug
that's off the menu stuff right there
you got to do your research it's the
special service yeah look at El Nino
hello we got Geoffrey up front to join
you got me up front and three laughs we
got three kids behind off excited yeah
from you
[Music]
what do you think guys yes I'm still
singing what do you think all right next
up time to watch some short film yes I
[Music]
was it very funny all right they came
down naked the birds all right glad you
enjoyed
[Music]
cut the end of a 34 favorite rice my
favorite ride in some future I'd and
test test test track Nina favorite ride
Jeffrey paper ride test track my
favorite bride was watching Eva eat all
that ice cream alcohol that was that was
great all right thank you guys for
joining us the three we'll see you again
tomorrow continue to believe
[Music]